that everyone it is time for us to get
ready for the most embarrassing live
show of the year my parents have just
sent me a box of all my old stuff that
was still in the house including Hanks
diary I'm going to read you from a
random page and Hanks diary if I can
read my handwriting and so you get a
glimpse of what we're going to be doing
in this live show today sorry I haven't
written in a few days I'm writing like
that because I have my good finger
apparently I had a bad finger swear
that's what it says so you will get to
find out about all the stuff that I
loved when I was 9 and also you will no
doubt be seeing embarrassing pictures of
both me and John Green so come and join
us there is a link in the doobly-doo I
may also play some songs but so please
come enjoy I will see you all there